-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
tonight.
And if you don't mind,
I'm gonna get to the news.
President Biden on Thursday
delivered
a rare prime time address
from Philadelphia's
Independence Hall,
and not,
as I originally thought,
the Upside Down.
[ Laughter ]
That is a wild lighting choice.
I...kept expecting him
to be interrupted by Vecna.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden traveled
to Pittsburgh yesterday,
which was his third trip
to Pennsylvania
in less than a week.
Not to be outdone,
Dr. Oz also made
his third trip to Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
Election day is nine weeks away,
and only time will tell
if Republicans gain seats
or if it was rigged.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
and First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
are set to host the Obamas
on Wednesday at the White House
for the unveiling of
their official portraits,
and you can tell
Biden misses the old days,
because this is
his official portrait.
[ Laughter ]
Maine Senator Susan Collins
said in a new interview
that she believes that Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
will get a vote on same-sex
marriage protections this month
but added that she hopes
he will "resist the urge to play
politics with the bill."
It's the Senate.
It's politics.
That's like saying
you hope the Jets resist
the urge to play football.
Okay, Jets...
[ Laughter ]
Jets is a bad example, but...
...you get the point.
During his speech in Wisconsin
yesterday, President Biden
said that not every Republican
is "a MAGA Republican,"
which is a little like saying
that not every zombie
eats brains.
Maybe, but they also don't mind
if the other zombies
eat your brain.
[ Laughter ]
Two Air France pilots
were suspended recently
after a physical fight
in the cockpit during a flight.
The fight
was reportedly so intense
that one of them
dropped his cigarette.
[ Laughter ]
New -- [ Chuckles ]
New footage of the Titanic
wreckage was recently released
in the highest screen resolution
currently available.
They zoomed in as far
as they could,
and bad news, you guys --
no survivors.
[ Laughter ]
[ Woman "aws" ]
Well, we know now.
It's high resolution,
so we know now.
You know what would be worse?
A survivor.
[ Laughter ]
"Aw."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
A large spill of Alfredo sauce
recently shut down an interstate
highway in Tennessee.
Well, it wouldn't be
the first time
Alfredo sauce
clogged a major artery.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we're -- You know,
when we read a story like that
we're worried, obviously,
that our monologue writers
caused the accident.
[ Laughter ]
According to New York State Park
officials,
hundreds of people at Long
Island beaches over the weekend
were stung by jellyfish.
At least, I assume that's why
they were all peeing
on each other.
[ Laughter ]
That's my assumption.
And finally, rapper Eminem won
an Emmy Award over the weekend
and now just needs a Tony Award
to achieve
so-called EGOT status,
so look for him this fall
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dear Evan Stanson"?